أعلنت المملكة العربية السعودية عن اقتراح جديد
تدعمه الأمم المتحدة لإنهاء الصراع المستمر منذ ست سنوات
في اليمن ، قال الأمير فيصل بن فرحان
للتلفزيون الرسمي السعودي
إن الاتفاق سيشمل وقف إطلاق النار
ورفع الحصار البحري
والجوي الذي تفرضه
السفن الحربية السعودية
على اليمن.  أنصار الله المعروفة باسم المتمردين الحوثيين
المدعومين من إيران في الشمال ، يأتي ذلك
بعد تحقيق سي إن إن كشف عن
عدم
السماح لناقلة نفط واحدة
بالرسو في ميناء الحديدة من
قبل السعوديين مما أدى
إلى تفاقم الأزمة الإنسانية المأساوية في
البلاد ،
أثار تقريرنا دعوات من قبل WFP World
Food  رئيس البرنامج
ديفيد بيسلي ومبعوث الأمم المتحدة في اليمن مارتن
جريفيس
دعا إلى رفع الحصار
لأسباب إنسانية
من جانبهم قال المتمردون الحوثيون في اليمن
إنهم لا يستطيعون بدء
كتب السلام ما لم يتم
إدراج الحصار كإظهار
لحسن النية
مع نائب وزير الخارجية.
وقال حسين عندها فقط أن ذلك سيسمح بإجراء
مفاوضات من
شأنها أن تؤدي إلى استنتاجات موثوقة
بين الجانبين  زيادة الضغط
على وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنطوني
بلينكين ،
حيث طرح أولاً خطة السلام الخاصة بهم
على الحوثيين التي تم رفضها
ثم التحدث مباشرة
مع وزير الخارجية السعودي
، يبقى أن نرى إلى أين يتجهون من
هنا
ولكن يبدو أن العالم
الانتظار بفارغ الصبر
ودفع الجانبين للالتقاء
وإنهاء المأساة في اليمن